150 chefs d'état et de gouvernement au
pied du mur
c'est dans un climat d'urgence que s'est
ouvert ce matin la coop 21
un seul mot d'ordre pour les
participants ne pas décevoir les
attentes
aller au delà des discours d'intention
un élan politique comme celui ci
pourrait ne jamais se représenter
vous avez entre vos mains le pouvoir
d'assurer le bien-être de sept
générations et des générations à venir
un à un tous les dirigeants présents se
sont exprimés y compris les plus gros
pollueurs de la planète
en tant que première puissance
économique du monde
mais en tant que plus importants pays
émetteurs de carbone
nous avons convenu qu'il est de notre
responsabilité d'agir
le compte à rebours est enclenché il
faut parvenir à un accord d'ici vendredi
11 décembre minuit un accord crucial
pour restreindre à 2 degrés le
réchauffement climatique de la planète
d'ici 2100 et ce n'est pas une mince
affaire pour les experts si l'on ne
change rien l'activité humaine actuelle
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
conduiront tout droit la planète vers
une augmentation de 4 degrés comment
limiter ce coup de chaud et éviter des
catastrophes naturelles irréversible
invivable c'est tout l'enjeu de la coop
21 l'unité affichée devant les caméras
résistera-t-elle aux jours et aux nuits
de négociations à venir
les dirigeants de la planète
parviendront-ils à tenir le plafond
symbolique des 2 degrés maximum
bonsoir à tous les trois jean marc
jancovici bonsoir vous êtes ingénieur
spécialiste de l'énergie et du climat
vous êtes associé fondateur de carbone 4
à 14 évidemment un cabinet de conseil
indépendant spécialiste de la transition
énergétique et vous avez publié le 4
novembre donc il y à peine un mois aux
éditions odile jacob dormez tranquilles
jusqu'en 2100 et autre malentendu est
assez provocant sur le climat et
l'énergie
et selon vous on a évidemment tort
d'essayer de mobiliser l'opinion avec la
figure de lot
blanc qui dérivent lamentablement sur la
banquise ce qui compte
ils se sont d'évoquer les conséquences
économiques géopolitiques et
démographique d'un réchauffement
climatique qui irait au delà de plus de
deux degrés on va évidemment en parler
ce soit à midan bonsoir vous êtes
historienne des sciences spécialiste des
négociations climatiques vous êtes
directrice de recherche au cnrs
gouverner le climat a coécrit avec deux
autres auteurs un autre auteur paru en
janvier 2015 aux presses de sciences po
pour vous le chiffre de 2 degrés est un
seuil symbolique des fini politiquement
d'ailleurs selon un objectif
scientifique
il ne faut pas lui accorder une
importance excessive abo pourtant gilles
boeuf bonsoir on est ravi de vous revoir
vous êtes biologiste conseiller
scientifique au ministère de l'ecologie
professeur à l'université pierre et
marie curie votre livre la biodiversité
de l'océan à la cité édition collège de
france fayard en avril 2014 selon vous
on parle de sauver la planète mais la
planète se fout totalement du
réchauffement climatique c'est nous les
humains qui avons un énorme problème
avec cela
alors on va démarrer dans un instant le
débat mais d'abord question vient à
perdre audrey lavoie humain comment
obliger tous les pv signé un accord et
surtout à l'appliquer sur une taxe pas
sévèrement ceux qui ne respectent pas
leurs engagements
évidemment ça va pas ko mais ce qu'il
aurait fallu prévoir de sanctionner les
mauvais élèves faire de l'écologie
punitive mais appliquée aux états cette
ce processus a beaucoup de défauts celui
là peut-être cette possibilité aurait
peut-être aidé les choses déçu c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de droit international
de l'environnement véritablement
contraignant et donc c'est un impératif
moral ce sont les sociétés civiles qui
peuvent peser pour contraindre les
gouvernements à tenir parole et a
emprunté des chemins plus vertueux mais
on est grosso modo dans un schisme de
réalité depuis 20 ans c'est à dire des
actes d'un côté une planète qui suit son
cours d'un côté et un des dix courses et
l'autre s'est pas encore mûr jean marc
jancovici faudra un jour un traité
international avec des mécanismes de
sanction
ces voix là on sent bien que les états
n'y sont pas prêts quoi dans les
nombreux malentendus puisque c'est le
thème du bouquin il y en a un qui est
conçu revend en permanence les résultats
qui sont atteignables dans le cadre de
ce genre de réunion pour donner un
parallèle qui vaut ce qu'il vaut une
réunion des nations unies c'est une
assemblée de copropriétaires syndics ou
en rentre dans la pièce en sachant pas
exactement quels problèmes à traiter et
où chaque copropriétaire a une voix
qu'ils soient propriétaires du triplex
du dernier étage ou du placard à balais
donc on imagine bien et tout doit se
faire par consensus donc on imagine bien
que ce jeu est par ailleurs il n'ya pas
ne serait-ce que la possibilité
d'appliquer un prix par exemple parce
que pour ça il faut que quelqu'un décide
de la nature de l'impôt de la base de
l'impôt du montant de l'impôt de qui va
collecter l'impôt de hourva l'argent sur
qui et c'est absolument pas dans le
mandat des nations unies de traiter de
ce genre mais alors les deux degrés
quand même qui a décidé en 2009
2° pour autant que je m'en souvienne
c'est un chiffre qui est sur la table
depuis un certain temps et il a été
politiquement acté à copenhague
oui avancé en 2002 alors qu'il faisait
était au doigt mouillé pourquoi
suggèrent des scientifiques dont quand
même dû du giec kids online racing
il a une racine scientifiques comme
toujours c'est à dire en gros c'est il
marque la fourchette d'incertitude
autour de ce que l'humanité a connu
depuis à peu près vingt mille ans et
dans lequel elle s'est développée et
août et donc ça a été considérée comme
le seuil dangereux qu'il ne fallait pas
dépasser alors ce chiffre est activement
c'est le chiffre du jour elizabeth 0 85
degrés celsius parce que les 2% vous
évoquez madame précisément on pense que
c'est la référence 2015 met pas du tout
en fait c'est 2%
c'est la limite est en fête 2° pardon
c'est pas 2 % entre 2° merci c'est
depuis dix ans
1680 par conséquent depuis cette date
nous avons déjà en fait réchauffer et
contribuer au ray charles bonnet 0 matic
les réchauffement de la planète est en
fait ce n'est plus 2% mais un degré 15
qu'il nous reste d'ici 2100 vincent
gilles boeuf
voilà donc que gilles boeuf on a en fait
très peu de temps ab la marge de
manoeuvre est très faible beaucoup plus
faible que les 2% le laisserait penser
on le savait sur les sept plaies
écologique que définit souvent la seule
sur laquelle il est trop tard pour
réagir pour empêcher un changement
climatique c'est le climat parce que ce
co2 qu'on accumule depuis un certain
temps il est là on en a pour un certain
temps et le climat a commencé à changer
bien produire des effets le jour à terme
et sur les oiseaux sont mes papillon
c'est clair sur ma vigne si on met
récolte alors il se passe des choses
particulières mais ce qu'il faut quand
même pas caché c'est que c'est pas le
principal problème qu'a aujourd'hui le
vivant sur cette planète ont détruit les
écosystèmes à une vitesse effroyable 23
millions d'hectares parti à l'indonésie
de forêts tropicales forestation en 2013
on surexploite aux décennies tout
partout le climat bien sûr imposer ses
effets aujourd'hui ça peut être la
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
oui jean marc jancovici non je voulais
dire les deux il faut un objectif
politique à un moment mais ce qui est
important c'est de fixer parce que tant
qu'on n'a pas fixé on n'a pas fixé le
plus qu'on appelle le budget carbone
parce qu'il ya une loi très simple qui
relie l'élévation de température qu'on
aura en 2100 avec la quantité
d'émissions qu'on a le droit de mettre
dans l'atmosphère entre 1850 et 2850 ces
révolutions industrielles henri jonça or
est bien c'est pas une date aléatoire
choisir en sciences et alors m début des
émissions de charles à 10 ans 80 au
début les émissions étaient tellement
faible que quand vous prenez comme date
de départ 1820 du 150 j'ai rien dis ça
change rien donc il ya une loi très
simple qui dit vous prenez les émissions
depuis le début de la révolution
industrielle jusqu'en 2100 vous faites
une règle de trois et vous avez
l'élévation de température qu'on aura en
2100 c'est vraiment très simple et donc
si c'est fait pardon et c'est fiable
ça résulte d'une accumulation de
connaissances scientifiques qui est
fiable en or de grandeur d'accord
d'accord la marque d'un ordre de
grandeur il a marre la marge d'erreur
derrière et quelques dixièmes de degré
d'un côté ou de l'autre
et une fois qu'on a dit ça on a fixé
globalement la trajectoire des émissions
j bien globalement encore une fois là
aussi une marge d'erreur et sadi par
exemple si on veut respecter ces deux
degrés qu'il
faut diviser les émissions mondiales par
trois d'ici à 2050 on peut se chicaner
ça peut être deux et demi trois et demie
enfin bon bref y est on est à peu près
par trois et ça te dit par exemple à
d'autres trucs pour commencer à faire un
peu touché du doigt qu'il faut mettre à
la ferraille la totalité des centrales à
charbon dans le monde dans les 30 ans
qui viennent
voilà ça dit dès lors de cette nature on
va revenir peut-être après sur les sur
ce qu'il faudra changer un mais déjà
avec ses 2 % et déjà avec cette
progression là le degré de dre degré
pardon je vais pas y arriver le sait
beaucoup plus que 2% fait le bond est là
le monde a déjà changé
gilles boeuf le tout ce qui a changé
déjà si on essaye de le visualiser de le
comprendre
on voit très bien on a fait un travail
avec les chances participative les
quelques temps c'est super robuste dix
mille personnes à 2,5 millions d'heure
d'observation sur l'europe de l'ouest
ban aux papillons ils ont fait 114 km
vers le nord sur 18 ans et nous donne 33
le déplacement des populations dans les
visions de langage des animaux des
animaux comme les maquereaux qu'on ne
trouvait pas dans certains pays et
compteront sur leur réserve en islande
et en norvège c'est ça des migrations
qui sont bouleversés on a reçu une
paysanne du niger il ya huit jours qui
nous disait que les migrations animales
au niger et c'est totalement bouleversé
et gilles boeuf je crois que vous êtes
très attaché aussi à l'acidification
aussi efficace que la série lost et de
lozère qui est directement lié aux
émissions de façon très claire comment
ça en fait c'est très simple c'est que
ce co2 qui ce retour dans l'atmosphère
il réagit à l'interaction avec la halle
la surface de la masse d'eau et le co2
dos a fait de l'acide carbonique est un
acide faible avec les s'édifier l'océan
pour l'instant on est rendu à quelques
centaines de mètres mais si on continue
comme ça on aura lost océans plus acides
jusqu'au fond faudra dire que l'océan ne
sera jamais acide c'est impossible
il a des effets tremperont très fort
mais et les plus acides qu'auparavant la
question c'est que cela s'est déjà passé
au cours de la terre ne prennent jamais
à cette vélocité jamais à cette vitesse
205 nous apprendre la grande
accélération et 30% plus acide et si on
continue à émettre sociaux deux dans
l'état actuel il risque d'être 50% plus
acide et ça ça nous préoccupe beaucoup
ce que vivent ces réagira température
qui chante quand ça va pas trop vite
c'est beaucoup plus difficile du régent
ça change trois vitesses d'acidité
évidemment on a parlé des animaux mais
pour les hommes pour les âmes c'est
cesser la hausse du niveau de la mer or
on sait que pratiquement tout
plus de 70% des villes
dans le monde sont construites sur les
démêlés côtière et dans les voisinages
des estuaires de fleuve et c'est donc ça
c'est ça veut dire ça a déjà commencé a
commencé oui le la fonte des glaces de
l'article ça a commencé
on voit bien que la les couches de glace
au beaucoup moins et pèse beaucoup plus
fragile et c est ça ça provoque hausse
du niveau de la mer ça provoque des tas
de alors vous avez évoqué françois
hollande et les migrations
le moringue rassure le mémo moudre en
effet environnemental oui c'est ça n'est
donc en fait le dérèglement climatique
produit déjà des migrations on écoute le
président qui en a parlé ce matin le
réchauffement annonce des conflits comme
la nuée porte l'orage
il provoque des migrations qui jettent
sur les routes plus de réfugiés que n'en
génèrent les guerres des états risquent
de ne plus pouvoir satisfaire les
besoins vitaux de leur population
françois hollande l'a parle des
migrations on est dans un contexte déjà
difficile sur le sujet assez tendue en
tout cas en europe et pas seulement en
europe on sait c'est un sujet qui a eu
énormément de voix lors de ce phénomène
de désertification d'assèchement des
sols et ses terrasses et nous sommes
déjà dans des phénomènes déjà des
déplacements de déplacement il ya des
territoires aujourd'hui on qui ne sont
plus habitables et qui pousse les
dérèglements pousse les gens à partir de
ce qu'on est en train de vivre en ce
moment en europe
c'est à des déterminants liés au
changement climatique
la méditerranée est en train de
s'assécher enfin le pourtour
méditerranéen est en train de s'assécher
la pluviométrie est en train de baisser
ça exerce une pression sur les
rendements des cultures ça rend les pays
encore plus importateurs qui ne l'était
avant où ça les fait devenir importateur
la syrie n'était pas importatrice de
céréales jusqu'en 2007
peut-être un petit lien de cause à
conséquence et tous les pays dans
lesquels fat les printemps arabes sont
directement liés à des émeutes de la
faim pénuries alimentaires etc et ces
émeutes de la faim ou un déterminant
climatique double dans le bassin
méditerranéen d'une part et d'autre part
il ya eu en 2010 une canicule redoutable
en russie
qui a privé le marché mondial des
céréales de la production et des
exportations russes cette année là avec
un prix des céréales qui a doublé sur
l'année semble y croire aux russes y lit
près les prévisions de l'onu en 2050 ce
serait de 250 millions de réfugiés
climatiques si rien n'est fait pourtant
annoncé rejoindre probablement ce que
disent mes deux voisins de droite bien
comprendre que ce genre de chiffres on
pourrait multiplier ou diviser par dix
tout simplement parce que on est en
train de faire une expérience pour la
première fois qu'ils sortent totalement
du cadre de ce qu'on ait cassé la barre
il va lever à 7 nokia pas d'actuaires
des risques du changement climatique
y'a pas d'addition et des règles de
trois savante à faire donc c'est un
grand saut dans l'inconnu
vous savez on n'a pas une près avec des
humains une sont humains à côté là on
pourrait faire la manip pour qu'on
aurait pu faire 450 fois l'expérience et
voir ce que ça donne mais on n'a pas
dans l'essai et il ya des gens qui
considèrent que déjà 2 degrés on est en
train de prendre un risque absolument
considérable pour les sociétés humaines
alors il ya aussi des conséquences
sanitaires des maladies tropicales des
maladies inconnues qui arrive qui nous
frappe et ça c'est lié au réchauffement
qu'ils exactement ça c'est déjà commencé
d'ailleurs et puis on a des données très
précises sur la manière dont 2,3 degrés
depuis ce jour avoir des effets sur
notre santé il n'ya pas très longtemps
il ya quelques jours des pneumologues
français ont fait le lien entre
réchauffement et pollution c'est à dire
que le réchauffement climatique va
favoriser des pics d'ozone ce qui va
créer une recrudescence de cancers du
poumon de maladies respiratoires
d'asthme et puis ça aussi des
conséquences plus en direct ses lois
mais ce qu'il prédit dans un rapport qui
a été publié il ya environ un mois un
rapport dans lequel on peut lire qu'un
réchauffement planétaire de 2 à 3 degrés
augmenterait de 5 % le nombre
d'habitants exposées au paludisme ça
représente une hausse de 150 millions de
personnes
gilles boeuf c'est dire qu'on a
aujourd'hui des insectes qui sont
porteurs de maladies qui peuvent arriver
en europe le chikungunya le palu
l'humour aedes albopictus ce petit
moustique qui nous embête beaucoup hein
eh ben il est partout dans le sud de la
france aujourd'hui ils étaient encore
six et en camargue et il est chez moi en
pays catalan on a des remontées mais qui
reliera paris
le palu en europe je crois pas trop trop
par contre le chikungunya certainement
plus doigt comme mallet tropicale la
dengue par exemple kiki dijon contact à
dakar en france si jamais il a commencé
ça c'est lié au réchauffement climatique
ou juste à la mondialisation la
circulation des marchandises des hard on
avait regardé au début auprès des
aéroports il avait des cas comme ça mais
là on n'est pas sur des choses qui sont
beaucoup plus massive avait dit remonté
j'étais en chine à quelques temps a
changé
j'ai vu comment les moustiques qui qui
fluctuent qui viennent du vietnam ou du
sud de la chine remonte maintenant vers
le nord et vous savez il ya quand même
eu deux moustiques nouveau à permet dans
le métro londonien a cédé sur assez
fantastique cette histoire là quand même
un jean 40 ans est ce qu'il ya un risque
qu'on n'arrive pas à tenir ces deux
degrés bercy va pas les tenir à l'avenir
dira à la tête d'accor vous dirai angers
parce que vous m'avez apostrophe leur
disant que je ne la connais pas
d'importance à ou 2 degrés j'accorde
beaucoup d'importance au 2° du point de
vue des impacts et des dégâts que ça
peut faire
là où j'accorde moins d'importance c'est
à la façon dont dans la négociation
actuelle on nous dit qu'on est à 2,7
n'est que je dois être à deux ça c'est
autre chose c'est à dire je crois que
les engagements actuels ne permettent
absolument pas de savoir exactement à
combien on l'est parce qu'ils portent
sur les dix 10 années maximum ou 15
années qui viennent centre d'un contrat
on peut facilement physiquement les
dépasser ça ne pose aucun problème
en fait quand on regarde le co2 qui est
potentiel qui correspond à ce qu'on peut
encore déstocker de terre en termes de
combustibles fossiles
il ya très très largement de quoi faire
les deux degrés en fait il ya très
largement de quoi il ya cinq ou six fois
de quoi faire les deux degrés donc ça
veut pas dire 14 ça veut dire qu'il ya
cinq ou six fois le co2 sous terre qui
permet de faire les deux degrés donc
physiquement ça ne pose pas de problème
on peut les dépasser
est-ce qu'on va le faire l'avenir le
dira la seule chose qui est absolument
certaine c'est que aucun système ne peut
rester indéfiniment hors d'équilibré
donc s'il faut bien avoir en tête c'est
que si ça n'est pas l'humanité qui mais
bon ordre à ce problème c'est le
problème qui se chargera de mettre bon
ordre l'humanité et ça on risque pas
aimer de la formule et variance un petit
mode des climato-sceptiques eux il y en
a de moins en moins en france à part
quelques barbant de l'académie des
sciences mais quasiment plus par contre
aux états unis un certain nombre de
climato sceptiques qui ont une influence
à travers les lobbys pétroliers
alors je vous présentez un sénateur
américain ils s'appellent james in
office est un fossile républicaine 81
ans pour qui tout baigne dans l'huile
thibault nolte le dégel présente dans
vanilla
ils sont au centre de l'histoire et
mérite forcément quelques déboires
tandis que la cap 21 est l'espoir de la
planète
un sénateur américain proche du lobby
pétrolier envisage de jouer les trouble
fête à paris alors faut-il fossilisés
james inhofe james inhofe et sénateur
républicain de l'oklahoma un état du
midwest en forme de hachoir gaver de gaz
et de pétrole
il est aussi président du comité
sénatorial sur l'environnement et
intervient sur toute nouvelle
législation environnementale amérique le
goudron c'est bon à washington il est
aussi réputé élu le plus
climato-sceptiques james et au climat ce
que le général custer était aux indiens
un fossoyeur
en 2009 il avait voulu torpiller
l'accord de copenhague
chaussés de bottes serpent il c'était
ridicule ise en éructant contre un
complot climatique
hollywood au onusien emmenés par barbra
streisand mme adam streisand quand on
n'a pas de banjo 7 en 2012 il a compilé
la somme de ses élucubrations sceptiques
au chrétienne dans un livre programme et
on février dernier remarquant que de
l'eau gelée tombé du ciel
jimmy a jeté une boule de neige en plein
sénat sur l'air de et mouk séductrice
décoré par sa clientèle politique jim et
notamment héros du trophée des
contribuables gardiens de la flamme au
centre pour la politique sécuritaire
noté a+ par le lobby des armes et
bienfaiteurs à vie chez les pétroliers
d'oklahoma inhofe est en réalité le
virus agressif d'une droite américaine
cacochyme et misanthrope la promesse
d'une ébullition climatique
merci thibault note e gilles boeuf lui
est une caricature il est vendue au
lobby pétrolier mais un climatologue
disait ce matin dans le figaro quand on
est face à un climato sceptiques il ne
faut pas le renvoyer dans ses cordes il
faut argumenter car les gens sont
parfois sincères lorsqu'ils ne voient
pas il se croit sincère vous savez j'en
ai j'annulais récemment à la sorbonne
après après une discussion et me voilà
monsieur le professeur je suis ton matos
et que ça semblait une profession et
d'évacuer moi je suis amoureux et sa
limite et le dessin a pas
d'argumentation comme ça voilà très bien
vincent question quand même on se dit
d'accord on va ça va être très difficile
même de contenir cette élévation de la
température mais est ce qu on ne
sous-estimé pas les faits de
l'innovation
on est au début d'une révolution
technologique avec le numérique est ce
que dans les 85 qui quelques années qui
nous restent avant d'atteindre 2100 on
ne va pas avoir on veut quand on voit
les sommes investies dans le la
recherche et développement des solutions
nouvelles
alors je vais tenir deux conclusions de
vieux cons grincheuse croissance verte
92,2 de propos de vieux con qu'un cheveu
j'ai regardé comment avait évolué et
l'efficacité énergétique de l'économie
dans le monde sur les 50 dernières
années
plus elles s'améliorent mieux on se
porte et bien de bruit depuis pardon le
début de la révolution numérique c'est à
dire depuis 2000 elle n'a pas bougé d'un
iota
dit autrement l'économie n'est ni plus
ni moins efficace aujourd'hui qu'en 2000
il ya un deuxième truc que j'ai regardé
sait combien on met de co2 dans
l'atmosphère pour faire 1 dollars de pib
eh bien depuis depuis pardon je vais
arriver l'essor des énergies
renouvelables en 2000 ça n'a pas bougé
d'un iota non plus parce que ce qui
s'est vraiment passé dans le monde sur
les 15 dernières années c'est
l'explosion du charbon beaucoup plus que
l'explosion des éoliennes et du solaire
non enfin en conclusion d'organisation
pour en venir sont gérés penser que le
temps emmène nécessairement les choses
dans le bon sens grâce au progrès
malheureusement des denrées claude hardy
reçu peut-être c'est une idée reçue
exactement ça ne correspond pas à ce
qu'on voit à midan donc quelles
préconisations quelles actions noté m
moi je pense que vers sa mère je sais
que n'a jamais fait ce processus
international et qu'on n'a pas assez
fait c'est d'identifier la
transformation qui est devant nous c'est
à dire l énorme
elle est colossal elle concerne nos
modes de produits dont comportement de
votre corps seulement le mode de vie
était requis de 10 personnes et donc
vous nous parler qui n'est pas les
politiciens aucun politique ne le dit
donc là la conscience de ce problème on
ne peut pas dire qu'elle n'est pas monté
à l'échelle planétaire
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'il ya quand même plus d'acteurs
concernés plus belle et citoyenne n'est
pas politique ce sac voilà elle oui ça
commence mais on en est encore loin du
compte et donc bon le monde
je ne peux pas dire que le monde n'est
pas ouvert les sociétés qui sont
plurielles à beaucoup de choses qu'il
est
peuvent les mettre en marche mais c'est
sûr c'est une bataille sur tous les
fronts très bien mais nous la mènerons
ici aussi entre autres merci à tous les
3 l'émission continue et xavier monnier
et jean mathieu pernin de point de vue
malicieux sur l'histoire et l'actualité
mais c'est juste après désintox ce soir
dash et les enfants suédois qui pointe
le doigt vers le ciel